so this comedian thought the only reason
why people aren't laughing at her jokes
is because she is a woman so she wore a
costume and pretended to be a man let's
see how her performance
went wow the self-awareness you don't
know what they're doing in these
Labs very loose
guidelines this lady wants me oh bro
brother this guy
stinks it just should to be a comic no
listen
because I can't do it as man I can't do
it as you were great what up guys
welcome to the just cly things YouTube
channel and welcome to my reaction
series before I start don't forget to
subscribe to the channel ring that
notification Bell and get yourself a
women shouldn't vote t-shirt today I am
going to be reacting to these women
become men to prove male privilege and
they instantly regretted it all right
let's see what's going on men or woman
who has a harder life woman women have a
hard life yeah woman yeah woman why
because we have to dealt with inequality
for I want the like River thing like
like the the world's smallest violin you
know a long time and currently do so as
well what do men have that woman don't
basic human rights which R do for
instance
um and you guys have free I'm not going
to say what it is but we don't have like
the same access for instance to birth
control like our men don't even have
birth control sub no no no Viagra for
instance your plan your medical plan
covers that and my medical plan doesn't
cover birth control a woman who
disguised herself as a man to find out
how it is to live as a man committed due
to the psychological scars of how
difficult life was as a man Nora Vincent
the author of self-made man has died by
assistance she was a radical feminist
who believe men lived on easy mode and
tried to prove it by disguising herself
a man for 2 years instead what she found
out is that men actually have it very
hard and wrote a book about her
experience in fact the experience was so
bad that she had to stop after 18 months
because she was starting to hate women
due to how bad the women treated her
when she believed she was a man men are
suffering they have different problems
that women have but they don't have it
better they need our sympathy they need
our love and they need each other more
than anything else they need to be
together do you think women understand
what it's like to be a man not at all no
clue no idea did you like being a woman
before Ned I did but I like it more now
cuz I think it's more of a privilege
being a man is much yeah it's really
true it's so funny because the women
will say that I hate women because I
point out the realities of how
privileged of lives we have they hate me
for it I mean I think I get more hate
than really I get hate from the left and
the right and you know what interesting
I was talking to this old red pillar I
don't want to say his name but it was
like a guy that was like he's kind of
like OG red pill like he was really big
in the early 2000s we were trying to get
him to come on the show and he ended up
having to kind of go out of the
Limelight because it affected his
business and he told me that it was
actually other men that ruined like what
he was doing it was other men that would
cancel his events or would like be a
problem for him men that are controlled
by women I just call women they
basically have the spirit of women in
them um because it and it's interesting
cuz sometimes you're like like I'll tell
a story about a man getting divorced and
the men will say that it's his fault
what are the guys supposed to do if the
woman wants to leave you can't do
anything for than a woman would ever
expect we Face rejection indifference
and unwarranted hostility far more than
any woman could even imagine I can
believe that the interview in her book
was more impactful with men than with
women men responded favorably to her
showing cause and effect about gender
beliefs and behaviors and were receptive
to her conclusion iions on the emotional
level because of a common ground of
evidentiary findings and logic based
thinking women being more emotion were
more likely to discard evidence and
logic and stick to their feelings no
matter whether the feelings prove
Justified or unjustified based on the
evidence that women are more emotional
or live through and logically presented
to them the lessons she learned broker
as both a woman and a person and as a
testament to how much of women's
empowerment is actually leading to
women's self-destruction well and it is
because we say that we're the same as
men we do not interpret information the
same way men do and really you know
women get on me but I'm just honest and
maybe some of my opinions sound out
there to you but I I don't think women
have the same mental capabilities that
men do obviously there are exceptions
the same way there are exceptional
children that are prodigies and and are
smarter than a lot of adults when it
comes to women in general we're not
smarter than men we're not more logical
than men and I think our buying
decisions prove that I mean how many
illogical things do we vote in into
existence like for example our student
debt how many of us signed up for
useless degrees that we didn't need um
another example is abortions how many
one out of three women have had an
abortion one out of three what what's
wrong what is
it how I love being a woman nobody told
me how
lonely being a man is had closer
friendships with random women I met in
the bathroom before I transitioned at
clubs because of how hope and women are
than I've had in my 8 years of
transitioning and then you transition
and you're just a guy walking down the
street that people cross the street so
that they're not near you and
friendships are so much harder to build
she's basically dipping a toe in the
pool and crying because it's too cold
while natural born men are either just
outright drowning or just trying to keep
their head above water just a little
longer it's actually not hard for men to
make friends it's a lot harder to get
respect as as men and if you are an
emotional transition man you definitely
won't make a lot of friends because our
brains are wired differently and the
experiences that we have as men are way
different someone transitioning didn't
grow up with the same diversity and
struggles as men also now that you've
cried publicly about your problems as a
man you are now seen as a weak man and
have lost attraction from women lost
respect from other men and and that's
the hard thing about being a guy is men
are just confused because they're told
One Thing by society and how to treat
women and what women want they're told
that women want emotionally available
men but it's just not true women want
somebody strong that they can look up to
they don't they don't want um you know
guys that are crying on Tik Tok
successfully Amplified your
isolation Barney Mac nice to meet you
what is it I have a comy central half
hour special and I'm also the voice of
Lenny on the Cartoon Network Joy cab
write all this down okay thanks bro can
I get some change for that do what you
do quit picking pushy hairs out your to
so this comedian thought the only reason
why people aren't laughing at her jokes
is because she is a woman so she wore a
costume and pretended to be a man let's
see how her performance
[Applause]
went ladies
gentl I love animals I would never buy
any uh
I would never buy any product that have
been tested on animals never because I
like to do that myself at
home make sure the control group is
isolated you don't know what they're
doing in these
Labs very loose
guidelines this lady wants me I can
totally tell I know I'm weird I'm a
weird dude oh
bro
wow the
self-awareness this guy
stinks I used to always carry a man
purse a MSE you ever carry one of those
what bro what are you talking about man
a
MSE I loved it I loved that MSE but I
was losing it I'd lose it everywhere I
was always leave my MSE around you know
I kept losing my MSE but I just started
carrying everything um my person my
pants I only lost my pants a couple of
times so that's really working out all
right thank you very much everyone good
night morning back ladies and
gentlemen you it was good didn't you see
me laughing I know but you were I felt
like you were laughing at me I wasn't
laughing at you that's
I he
was he really was
this is simping now what what is sing I
I throw this term around a lot so maybe
I think I should give you guys a
definition simping is when men put
women's emotions above their logic men
naturally are more logical than women
men naturally know what is true and when
they bend the truth for women I call
that simping so right there he's bending
the truth for women's feelings at your
jokes and how you hand that was good I'm
telling you that was no that was good
don't get don't upset I just should to
be a comic no listen because I I'm I
can't do it as man I can't do it as
woman you were great you were great
you're you're great as a woman you're
better as a woman somebody's going to
come out here to see like some dude
cry his eyes out no I'm telling
you you are great listen to me I'm
serious like I was I don't even care
about this stupid dog I'm telling
you she was so duded into and that's
women have no idea how much better the
world treats us because we're a woman
imagine if that was the guy crying
because he bombed you would not get that
level of sympathy thinking nobody
laughed cuz she's a woman came to find
out she's just not funny after the next
step is to accept that reality and do
the only thing she can do and that is to
improve her performance one of the
comments says it's always hard when
someone realizes they aren't a victim
and that their failure is their own
everyone has an excuse in someone to
blame for their failure these days the
sad fact is most people live in that
kind of denial the fact that she's
somehow genuinely felt that her male
disguise is realistic enough to convince
the entire crowd is really the actual
joke here her crying at the end just
goes to show that it's not about
anything to do with social justice and
that's why I say the sing it doesn't
help us it really doesn't um it's
comforting but when we don't know what
reality is we can't improve um and the
problem is we're we're told we're
princesses from the time we're 5 years
old quality it's for their own personal
validation they did an experiment with a
group of of women and they put scars on
their faces and they told these women
that they're going into a job interview
and the purpose of the experiment is to
find out whether people with facial
disfigurements face discrimination uh
they showed them the scars in the mirror
the women saw themselves with these
scars and as they LED them out of the
room they said we're just going to touch
it up a little bit and as they touched
it up they removed the scarring
completely so the women went into the
job interview thinking that they are
scarred but actually being their normal
self and the result of the experiment is
that those women then came back
reporting massively increased level of
discrimination indeed they many of
thinking you're a victim is a disease
it's literally a disease even guys um I
mean you guys know what happened last
year here that was so crazy it was so
crazy like victim mentality it it's they
it'll convince you that the world is
against you and a lot of times it's not
usually people are willing to help you
back with comments that the interview
had made that they felt were referencing
their facial disfigurement I wonder if
they did that with men if it would be
the same I don't think so this is why I
think this ideology of victimhood is so
dangerous because if you pre the serpent
whispered to Eve not Adam to people
constantly that we're all oppressed then
that primes people to look for that yeah
and I I think women really in general
have no idea how hard men's lives are
women we have it way easier we get free
drinks at the bar we get preferential
job treatment um we I've even heard that
we get preferential treatment in schools
all of these things favor women all of
societ favors women and there are so
many women that could not live life as a
man they we could not because a lot of
us have not faced reality from the time
we were a kid um but let me know what
you guys think in the comments like the
video on your way out subscribe to the
channel I'll talk to you next time I